بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول الله تعالى الله الذي رفع
السماوات بغير عمد ترونها ثم استوى على
العرش وسخر الشمس والقمر كل يجري لاجل
مسمى يدبر الامر يفصل الايات لعلكم بلقاء
ربكم
توقنون درسنا موصول حول ايات سوره الرعد
من كتاب
الله وقد وصلنا بالامس الى ال قوله تعالى
ثم استوى على
العرش قد وصلنا امس الى قوله ثم استوى على
العرش وسخر الشمس
والقمر سه
الر
قران الله س وتالى
الله up that you can see and then he
rose above the
throne he has
set the sun and the moon in mo each
mov to a
designated to
‏all and
he does make c his in order that you
all قول تعالى ثم استوى على
العرش ذكرنا ان
الاستواء
الاستواء من صفات الله
الفعليه
والقاعده ان
الصفات صفات الله سبحانه
وتعالى تثبت كما
جاءت فنحن لا نحرف المعنى المعنى وعلى
ظاهره نثبته كما
جاء واما
الكيفيه كيفيه هذا الامر
فاننا نفوض ذلك الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى كيف لا وهو سبحانه وتعالى لا تدركه
الابصار وهو يدرك الابصار كيف لا وهو
سبحانه من لا يحيط به
علما فنحن نفعل
ذلك في بعض المخلوقات التي هي
خارج اطار مع ما
اعتدناه في هذه
الدنيا في المخلوقات الجنه مثلا
الجنه وصفها الله سبحانه وتعالى باوصاف
عظيمه
معانيها
واضحه كيفيتها غير
واضحه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يروي ان
الله تعالى يقول اعددت لعبادي الصالحين ما
لا عين رات ولا اذن سمعت ولا خطر على قلب
بشر ما خطر على قلب
بشر مع كل هذه الاوصاف التي جاءت في كتاب
الله
للجنه وفي بلسان عربي
مبين لافح
الناس
والاهتمام الذي كان لدى
الصحابه يتصورون هذه الاوصاف ومع ذلك لم
يخطر على قلب بشر اذا
كيفيه صفات الجنه فانها
ما خطرت على قلوب
العباد هذه كما قال تعالى مثل الجنه التي
وعد المتقون
مثل فالله سبحانه وتعالى استوى على العرش
هذا المعنى
واضح كيفيه هذا
الاستواء غير معقول للانسان الانسان لا
يستطيع ان يتصور ذلك لذلك العلماء
يقولون ما جاء في كتاب
بالله من صفات ومن
افعال من صفات الله ومن افعال الله وكذلك
ما جاء عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مما
ثبت عنه من من صفات الله وافعال
الله فاننا نثبت ذلك نثبت ما جاء في وصف
الله في كتابه وفي سنه رسوله صلى الله
عليه وسلم نثبت ذلك
كله بغير تحريف ولا تاويل ولا تكييف ولا
تمثيل هكذا
يقولون نثبت هذه
الامور من غير تحريف
للمعنى ولا
تكييف
كيفيه ولا تمثيل لا نمثله سبحانه وتعالى
بخلقه ولا تشبيه لا
نشبهه سبحانه وتعالى نثبت هذا نقول ثم
استوى على العرش استوى الله تعالى اي على
على عرشه استواء يليق بجلاله
وسلطانه المعنى واضح
والكيفيه لا
تدركه
العقول وسخر الشمس والقمر سخر يعني ذلل
الشمس والقمر جعل الشمس والقمر في خدمه
الانسان الله عز وجل سخر الشمس
والقمر يجريان في خدمه الانسان بما ينفع
الناس يقول كل يجري لاجل مسمى كل منهما
يجري لاجل مسمى
لاجل لزمن مسمى والله عز وجل يذكر انه سخر
الشمس
والقمر لنعلم عدد السنين
والحساب فعلمنا الله سبحانه وتعالى ذلك
وجعل الشمس والقمر في مصالح
العباد يدبر
الامر سبحانه وتعالى الامر اي جميع الامر
فاللام هنا للجنس يدبر جنس
الامر او للاستغراق يدبر جميع الامر
سبحانه
وتعالى يفصل الايات هذه الايات التي تدل
على وحدانيه
الله وكما ذكرنا ليست
هذه للتدليل على وجود الله فهذا لم يكن
امرا كان هذا امر مفروغ منه اصلا في مكان
وزمان النبي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم ما
كان في حدا من العرب ينازع في وجود
الله ابدا يثبتون وجود
الله
و يجادلون في وحدانيه الله في العباده
نعبد الله وحده دون ما سواه هذه
مشكله اجعل الالهه الها واحدا اله يعني
المعبودات الها واحدا معبودا
واحدا هذا لشيء عجاب هكذا المشركون
قالوا وقال وقال الله تعبيرا عن
اعتقادهم ما نعبدهم الا ليقربونا الى الله
زلفا فالله سبحانه وتعالى واحد في الخلق
والرزق وهم يؤمنون بذلك المشكله يعبدون
غيره
ويزعمون
انهم يعني يتوسلون بهذه المخلوقات وبهذه
الالهه يتقربون بها الى
الله كما يتقرب الى ملك من الملوك له
وزراء لا تستطيع ان تاتي الملك فتاتي من
يعرف من يعرف الوزير من يعرف
الملك ف تتقرب منه فهو يشفع لك عند الله
لذلك تجد في القران ان الله تعالى احيانا
ينفي الشفاعه صح ولا لا قل لك ما في شفاعه
يوم
القيامه وفي بعض ايات يثبت
الشفاعه يقول تعالى من ذا الذي يشفع عنده
الا
باذنه ويقول سبحانه وتعالى لا بيع فيه ولا
خله ولا
شفاعه كيف نجمع هذه في نفس
الصوره كيف نجمع بين اثبات الشفاعه ونفي
الشفاعه الجواب ان الشفاعه المنفيه هي
الشفاعه
التي في اذهان
المشركين المشركون يزعمون ان هذه الشفاعه
لابد ان يقبلها الله وهذه الشفاعه
اذا تثبت لهم اذا تقربوا الى الشافع فهم
يتقربون الى هذه الالهه والالهه يفرضون
شفاعتهم كما ان الملك لا يرد شفاعه
الوزراء
وسبحانه وتعالى بل لله المثل
الاعلى الملك في الدنيا لا يستطيع رد
شفاعه الشفعاء لما
شفاعه مثلا الوزير لانه يحتاج الى الوزير
والوزير الوزير يعين هو الوزير مهم لا بد
ان يتبادل معه المعروف الله سبحانه وتعالى
لا يحتاج الى
احد حتى تفرض الشفاعه عليه سبحانه وتعالى
لذلك هو ينفي الشفاعه تاره ويثبت الشفاعه
تاره فهو ينفي الشفاعه
الشفاعه التي في اذهان المشركين ما نعبدهم
الا ليقربونا الى الله زلفه هؤلاء شفعاؤنا
عند
الله و يثبت الشفاعه التي هي باذنه سبحانه
وتعالى لا يشفعون الا لمن
ارتضى فالله سبحانه وتعالى اذا ارتضى
المشفوع له ورضي شفاعه الشافع وكان موحدا
فان الله تعالى يقبل
الشفاعه يقول يدبر الامر يفصل
الايات
ايات
ايات الوهيته سبحانه وتعالى انه الواحد
المستحق للعباد دون ما
سواه
يقول
لعلكم بلقاء ربكم توقنون لعل هنا عاده
للترجي في لغه العرب لعل كذا يعني يرجى
كذا لكن هذا ليس في كتاب الله في القران
لعل تاتي ويراد
بها وجوب الوقوع اذا جاء يعني عسى في كلام
او
لعل فانه على على التحقيق في كتاب الله
بلقاء ربكم توقنون هذه مساله ايضا نازع
فيها
المشركون نازع في البعث قالوا ما في
بعث ما في بعث كيف
يبعث
الخلق كيف تبعث العظام وهي رميم استبعدوا
هذه هل استبعدوا جميع ربوبيه الله جميع
افعال الله لا استبعدوا
اجزاء فهم اثبتوا ان الله الذي خلق اول
مره واستبعدوا ان يعيد الخلق بعد ان بعد
ان ذهب في
الارض وهذا يدل على تناقض
عظيم
فهم تناقض في الوهيه الله في عباده الله
وتناقض في اثبات قدره الله سبحانه
وتعالى تناقض حيث قالوا لم يخلق ولم يرزق
ولم يدبر الا
الله لكن عبدوا مع الله غيره تناقض هذا
تناقض وايضا يثبتون ان الله خلق الخلق اول
مره ثم ينفون اعاده
الخلق مع انه عقلا هوهون اعاده الشيء اهون
من انشائه اول مره صح ولا لا لذلك يستدل
الله سبحانه وتعالى بذلك عقلا يقول وهو
اهون
عليه ايش اهون عليه يعني اعاده الخلق
اهون من انشائه اول مره هل يعني ان بعض
الاش اشياء يستصعب الله وبعض الاشياء لا
يصعبها طبعا لا المقصود وهو اهون عليه
يعني
على تقدير
الانسان الانسان اذا نظر الى نفسه انشاء
الشيء اول مره اصعب بكثير من
اعادته فهم تنازعوا
في البعث تنازعوا في البعث
لذلك القران اكثره في ماذا الايمان بالله
واليوم الاخر الايمان بالله واليوم الاخر
الايمان بالله واليوم الاخر
لماذا لان هذه المساله وهذه
المساله يعني هاتان المسالتين
هما
راس مصيبه عند العرب في زمن النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم ينازعون في وحدانيه الله
في الوهيته في
عبادته يقولون نعم هو الخالق الواحد وهو
المالك الواحد لكن نعبد
غيره تقربا اليه هذه مساله فكما انكم
اثبتم ان ليس ثم خالق الا الله فلا يستحق
العباده الا الله على حسب على حسب قواعد
هذه المساله الاولى المساله
الثانيه ينازعون في اعاده الخلق والبعث
اليوم
الاخر والله سبحانه وتعالى يقول كما
تثبتون ان الله هو الذي انشا الخلق وبدا
الخلق اول مره فهو اهون عليه على
حسب قواعد وتجاربكم ايها الناس
على اعاده الخلق لذلك كان كانت هذه
المساله وهذه المساله اعظم مسالتين
في التفرقه بين المؤمن والكافر في زمن
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لذلك كان
المعيار الايمان بالله واليوم الاخر
المسلم يؤمن بالله واليوم الاخر في ذاك
الزمن الى قيام الساعه لكن
هذه راس المساله لذلك من جاء فانه يريد ان
من جاء يسلم لابد
ان يقر ب وحدانيه الله في العباده لا اله
الا الله يعني لا معبود بحق الا الله هذا
معنى لا اله الا
الله
ولا بد ان يقر باليوم
الاخر
فهو يقول سبحانه وتعالى لعلكم بلقاء ربكم
توقنون الذي فعل كل هذا فهو سبحانه اقدر
على بعثكم يوم القيامه وكذلك فان هذه
الامور التي فعلها الله رفع السماوات بغير
عمد ترونها استوى على العرش انزل
الكتاب الى اخر ما ذكر ما الحكمه من هذه
كلها ما الحكمه اذا كان فقط الانسان يموت
ثم يذهب في الارض سدا ايحسب الانسان ان
يترك
سدى ما في
فائده
الظالم يهرب
بالموت وينجو
من مظلومه بالموت يموت خلاص وايضا المظلوم
يموت
ولا ياخذ حقه من ظالمه لابد ان يكون ثم
بعث ف لذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى فصل هذه
الايات في
وحدانيته في هذين الامرين الاساسيين الامر
الاول عباده الله وحده دون ما سواه الامر
الثاني الايمان بالبعث والحساب واليوم
الاخر
نكتفي بهذا القدر نترجم ان شاء الله تعالى
ونستمر دا باذن
الله
ر الله سبحانه
وتالى
ال مم
را
open ‏are the opening
letter سه
الرش
before
that many of the chapters of the
قران they are initiated they are opened
up letter or letter them we take
all chapters of the قران that beg with
letters and we look
‏and that those letters
are the most important necess and they
are the root letters if
will the
alphabet
andys letter
‏very rigorously by the schar islam of
ancient and contemporary times and
continue to be
so but as from these different elements
that we see with regards to these
letters what do these letters mean what
they
me the answer is letter no def
‏because we in the arabic dictionary
when we look in
the poetry of the arabs and the words of
the air they don't use letters this
together in this way so they don't have
a definition in themselves have a mean
they are
artic ‏x z abc right when we say abc we
me something elementary we say xy z we
me
something a to completely
entirely the words x y z or the letters
xy z a they don't have a meaning in
themselves if you look diction
noc these are tye
‏find a definition for the letter a in
definition for the letter z
in but the listener understands a to z
mean entirely thor
completely from the to
end and
الله سبحانه
وتال
قران
letter ال
مم محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ‏use letter as as
they however in these letter at our
dispos we are unable to produce a book
this book not
even chapters these 10 chapter قران
notter chapter
قران قران
ال مم
را ال
[Silence]
صرر الله سبحانه وت
الله legislative will to
humanity the book all the prophets and
messengers given the
ب الله سبحانه
وتالى
ches
‏as wor
اللهي سبحانه
وتالى اله الا الله محد رسول الله لا اله
الا
الله الله محد رسول
الله is rightfully followed
unconditionally from among man محد صل
الله عليه
وسلم
الله الله عليه
ملك ايات
الكتاب
veres are
ver of الله and that which has been sent
down to you from your lord is in the tru
yet most people will not believe most
people do not believe this is inter
concept
‏and that is
followers amoun just numes that
articulate success or
fail mean the only success num we have a
lot of
people follow this particular
l
‏enough ofid to have a l of people the
majority of people or all people believe
a particular idea that is not enough
to act as an evidence for the validity
of that thing we say for instance most
people in the world
believe that that most people in the
world
believe that
ع عليه السلام jes
was
make most people in the
world
believe محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
قران most
people
‏that allah should not be wor that
others can be worship along with him
make true no most people believe in the
trinity most
people believe in this and that this
things do not this is not evidence on
own and so it's also not an evidence
when people most people do not believe a
particular idea
‏that the قران is from الله most people
do not that on not not now make untrue
make it untrue not from no and the
reason why the majority of human beings
is not considered an evidence because
the majority of human beings they are
not driven
by objectivity they are driven by subje
‏are people gravitate toward fanty they
do not gravitate
toward reality that's the
truth الله سبحانه
وتالى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
ران
قران قران الله سبحانه
وتعالى الله
is
‏to
schill are there no
pillars and different scholars have
different opinions on this based on
the
grent corre
op ‏can ra anything without some sort of
support underneath
he says and then he rose above the
throne in a way which is befitting to
his majesty beyond our
comprehension and he set the the sun and
the moon on their courses
each
moving to designated
time
‏all all
aff all سبحانه
وتالى and he clarifies and breaks down
all of the evidences evidences of what
evidences that
he سبحانه
وتالى
قران
قران الله ‏the existence of was not ever
really in question the existence of a
creator that was never really a topic of
contention the issue of contention
was
قران regards to that meaning they
come in that spirit ‏to articulate and
prove the worship without any
partn he says
he clarifies and breaks down all of
these evidences in order that you may
become certain of the meaning meeting of
your
lord we
will
شاء وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين